so animals communicate all animals
communicate
and that's what really interests me what
are they saying how much are they saying
why are they saying it
and a lot of the work that i do is about
finding out
mechanisms finding out how different
traits and abilities evolved so when you
see animals or any kind of life and you
notice that they have similarities so
we have forearms and legs and dogs do as
well then
there's a couple of reasons why that
could be i mean it could be just that
they come from a common ancestor and we
all inherited
these traits however if you observe two
animals with
similar properties it may be that they
don't inherit those properties from a
common ancestor but they just evolved
them both
separately because they were really good
solutions to the problem
that they were facing and the obvious
example of that for instance is
wings we know birds have wings bats have
wings
even insects have wings so wings are
convergent
that's convergent evolution
[Music]
so one of the really interesting things
about wolves and dolphins is they're
very very similar they don't sound like
they're similar but they really are
um they're both very social animals
they're both very intelligent animals
and they communicate
to establish their groups and their
societies so actually
their calls and their and the sounds
that they make are very very similar
they're different in pitch but that's
about it if you slow down a dolphin
whistle
it sounds just like a wolf howl
[Music]
it was incredibly striking just how
similar that visual representation
of a wolf howl appeared to the
representations of the dolphin whistles
that i'd been working with
and that was a that was a an important
moment it's it's it's not a novel
observation
but it made me realize that that the
processes behind
why these animals use these particular
kinds of sounds
were probably similar there was probably
something similar going on
once you start finding all these common
behaviors and common mechanisms
on earth then it's a very small jump to
realize that these are the same
mechanisms that are going to be working
elsewhere in the universe and a lot of
the same constraints that
animals face on earth a lot of the same
problems animals have to solve
on earth are similar problems to the
ones that are going to solve elsewhere
so the one thing that we can be really
confident of is that
complex life or complexity of any sort
really can only only arise in
in one way that's if it accumulates
slowly nothing
pops into being incredibly complex and
sophisticated like an animal
so they must have come from simpler
organisms and that process of
simplicity accumulating complexity
is what we call evolution on earth and
these are really the these are the
things that
we know are going to be in common um
across the universe there are also
constraints on on life that we know are
common across the universe so for
instance all life needs energy
you can't have life without energy and
that's going to be the same whatever
planet you're on so some of the things
about extraterrestrial life are going to
be very surprising there's no doubt
about that a lot of
a lot of the way the animals are on
earth is the result of coincidences
and and that's going to be the same on
any planet but there are some things
that are going to be
in common um things like uh simple
things like
having predators and prey if energy is
something that all life needs then then
sooner or
on other later is that animals or the
equivalent of animals will come together
in societies they'll come together in
groups
because there are many things that you
can do better in a group than you can do
on your own
so so many of the behaviors we see on
earth will be replicated elsewhere in
the universe as well